buen trabajo ahora que sabemos cómo
volver nítida una imagen calculemos
exactamente dónde está el punto de
enfoque nítido conocemos el punto donde
los rayos principales y paralelos se
intersectan colocamos una vez más el
punto del origen de nuestro sistema de
coordenadas en el centro de la lente y
dejemos que el punto que vamos a enfocar
tenga las coordenadas x 0 0 el radio
principal pasa a través del origen y el
punto x 0,0 por lo tanto la ecuación de
esta recta es sencillamente llego a la
de 0 dividido entre x 0 por x el rayo
paralelo pasa a través de dos puntos que
conocemos el punto donde toca la lente
que está en cero de cero y el punto
focal de la lente que está en menos f
cero tiene una pendiente de 0 sobre f y
una ordenada de 10 0 por lo tanto la
ecuación de esta recta es igual a 10 0
sobre f por x más de cero
vamos a igualar estas ecuaciones
tenemos que 0 sobre x 0 por x es igual a
10 0 sobre f por x de cero
entonces dividimos todo entre 0 para
obtener 1 sobre x 0 por x
igual a 1 sobre f por x 1 ahora
dividamos todo entre x lo cual nos da 1
sobre x 0 igual a 1 sobre f + 1 sobre x
observa que la x de esta ecuación es la
coordenada x donde las rectas se
intersectan de acuerdo con nuestro
diagrama esto sucede cuando x es igual a
menos y nuestro diagrama también nos
indica que x0 es igual a la distancia
del objeto y entonces tenemos que 1
sobre o es igual a 1 sobre efe - 1 sobre
y lo cual generalmente convertimos en 1
sobre o más 1 sobre y es igual a 1 sobre
f tam tam
a esto se le conoce como la ley de la
lente simple esta ley dice que un objeto
que está a una distancia o de la lente
con una distancia focal efe entra en
foco a una distancia
en el siguiente ejercicio pondremos a
prueba tu comprensión de este concepto